en
ce moment vous regarder confortablement
l'émission découverte et si charles
tisseyre bienvenue à découverte sans en
prendre conscience votre coeur bat comme
il le fait cent mille fois par jour
[Musique]
chaque battement cardiaque affecte votre
perception du monde
influence la manière dont tu ressentais
les stimuli extérieurs
c'est ce qu'ont découvert des chercheurs
allemands de l'institut max planck
le coeur se contractent des pompes le
sang dans les artères c'est la systole
puis le coeur se détend et se remplit de
sang à nouveau c'est la diastole
ce que nous ne savions pas c'est que ces
fluctuations module notre capacité à
percevoir les stimuli externes
[Musique]
à l'aide d'impulsions électriques subtil
les chercheurs ont découvert que pendant
la systole et volontaires étaient moins
susceptibles de les détecter
une composante de l'activité cérébrale
celles associées à la conscience est
alors supprimés
en d'autres termes nous semblons moins
bien percevoir notre environnement au
moment où le coeur se contractent et
pompe le sens à travers le corps
al'inverse lorsqu'une coeur se détend en
enregistre les sensations externe plus
clairement
l'activité cérébrale change donc au
cours du cycle cardiaque pourquoi cet
étrange phénomène
en allégeant notre niveau de conscience
durant la systole cela nous évite d'être
constamment dérangés par les mouvements
du coeur
[Musique]